when and how is the right way to skip
the chain of command when you feel like
your direct superior is a part of the
problem big one big one because this is
very very problematic and skipping the
chain of command is a last resort it is
a last resort why is it a last resort
because when you skip the chain of
command you're breaking the trust I just
talked about you're breaking it the
relationship that you've been building
you're damaging it it's not good
sometimes it's unsalvageable by the way
sometimes when you skip the chain of
command you will never be able to
recover from that now of course if
there's something that the your media
sphere is doing that's illegal or
immoral or unethical if that's the case
then it's actually your duty to go above
them in the chain of command
now do you still first report it to them
and say hey what you did is wrong we're
not gonna do that
yes you should tell them first unless
it's gonna you know cause you to get in
some horrible situation now this is an
interesting thing that I thought about
let's say you and I are working together
and and you're my boss and let's say
you're doing something that's immoral
illegal unethical right and I watch you
do it and and I and I see you leaning
towards it I'm like oh I think he's
gonna do something that's illegal right
here and I don't say anything and then I
watch you do it and then I run up the
chain of command report you and bust you
right you got to be careful with that
and and I think when you work for
someone or when someone works for you
you need to lay it right out of the gate
like hey this is where I stand like I'm
not gonna cover for you if you do some
stupid illegal things you don't wait for
them to do it and then drop the hammer
on them maybe I'm being overly fair and
maybe we should be all out to get people
that are you know doing something that
they shouldn't be doing part of the
problem yeah I actually I I believe
that's my belief is when I when I meet
you and I say hey what's going on and
you make a little crack you know you
make a little joke you know you say well
you know it's not like that's not like
the it's not like the customers can
really see that money you know let's say
you're gonna skim money for all right
yeah yeah you make a little joke like
that you know you and you're and what
you're doing is testing the waters with
me right you're testing my ethical moral
stuff like yeah there's no way they
would ever know and besides we pretty
much work for it anyways right right
you're gonna see if you're gonna get
that reaction so you know we just you
know sometimes we had to get a little
charge a little extra on that install
right maybe we're maybe we're some kind
of installers at a house usually yeah
you know I usually you know throw a
little upcharge on here
they never know if that's type of wall
whatever right you throw that test at me
it's my duty if I'm the type of person
that's gonna report you for skimming
money from the customers then I should
tell you like hey man that's not cool
now ya know those customers they you
know here's my view is those customers
that we're out there trying to do this
install for they had to work hard for
that money I don't want to be taking it
from them mmm now you kind of know yeah
you better not be doing that in front of
me yeah as opposed to me smiling and
going along with your joke and then
three months later I report you know I
turn over a report to the boss man yeah
so I don't think that's very ethical
evil yeah it's kind like a Mack lead to
a little bit of a backs are there cases
of course where somebody's doing
something that's just outrageously
unethical and you didn't know about it
or something you pretty much know though
you can tell when people are doing shady
things yeah so so I think that that is
something okay so let me let me let me
let me close this bar or at least make a
point of this thought my point of this
thought is it's the same thing that
happens a lot where people don't like to
have hard conversations so it's an easy
conversation when you say you know those
customers never know where their money
goes and it's only 12 bucks a thing and
it's no big deal the easiest thing for
me to do is to smile and say yeah yeah
that's the easy and and and that's not
that big of a deal right
it gets so much harder the further we go
down that road it gets harder and harder
and harder because then you start saying
hey you know it's only you know we've
been skimming like 12 bucks guess what
they never noticed this other charge
either and I can get him for $62 mmm and
then all of a sudden it's a harder
conversation so have the hard
conversation earlier it'll make it
easier for you so that being said now
how do we escalate above you and the
chain of command first of all my goal is
to not escalate above you in the chain
of command my goal is to actually raise
the situation to you and bring it up to
you and say hey echo you know the way
we've been doing this job you know I
think we should do it a different way I
think there's a better way to do it I
think there's a better way to treat the
customer whatever whatever the thing is
better way to attack this target
whatever the thing is and I'm gonna have
that conversation with you like two
three four or five times to try and get
you to listen to me now if the
conversation doesn't work I'm gonna
escalate it even further you know what
I'm gonna do I'm gonna actually do a
little write-up I'm gonna write a point
paper let me say echo I was listening
and thinking about what we're doing how
we're hitting this target or how we're
loading out our guys or whatever and I'm
gonna write you up on paper I'm gonna
lay it out for you to lay out what my
plan is what the cost benefits are and
make that very clear to you so that way
I'm giving you every ample opportunity
to listen to what I'm saying right and
I'm probably even gonna say hey maybe we
should run this by you know the boss
mm-hmm to see what they think
yeah because if you just keep
disagreeing with me and I said you know
COO can I you mind if I bring us the
boss and see what he thinks
yeah now what are you gonna say to that
most most the medians are not gonna be
happy but I'm giving you a heads up yeah
because I'm just trying to play open and
it kind of doesn't it kind of make them
reflect to where it's like hey I'm gonna
you know bring soup on there what do you
say no don't bring that to the boss it's
kinda like God it makes it real over
that they're not doing correct you know
so so yeah you say and you might get a
boss you might get a boss he goes yeah
bring it to him he's gonna say the same
thing I'm telling you
and then you go um maybe I'm wrong yeah
wrong about this procedure or maybe I'm
wrong about how we're going to attack
this target
but it is and also this is a hard
conversation to have the hard
conversation to say someone man can we
just bring this the boss er and and and
again I'm not saying you say hey I'm
gonna bring this to the boss you say hey
would you mind if I got his opinion
would you mind if I see what she said
about this and that way we're what we're
not saying I'm going to the boss I'm
going above your head you can't stop me
no that's not what I'm talking about so
there's that the other thing that you
could so that's that's sort of a direct
approach with your immediate boss which
starts by the way with an indirect
approach at being like hey echo you know
it's think about the way we're hitting
these targets wouldnt it be smart maybe
if we hit them from over here do you
think that would work and now we're just
open up the conversation so we've done
that I can also go indirect with your
boss right so so your direct boss who's
now two up above me in the channel and I
can go indirect with him at the water
fountain right yeah hey oh yeah thanks
but I'll see everything's going great
yeah doing a great job
yeah worker yeah I'm on echos team yeah
yeah no it's really good it's good it's
a tough mission but you know we're we're
always exploring new ways studios we're
looking at some other options I was
thinking another way to hit those
targets to kind of like coming in from
this direction oh that's all I did was
just drop a little plan a little C's you
know have that conversation come up and
I'm just gonna that's what I'm gonna do
plant a little seeds and try and get
them to maybe say all that sounds like a
really good idea what did that go think
of that I you know actually I haven't
talked to echo about it in full detail
but I will die Gerber try a man that
boss asked me about this and he was
mentioning you know I mentioned this
other way of doing it and he thought it
might be a good idea and I just want to
give you a heads up in case he says
anything I didn't really have a chance
you know whatever so we're just we're
playing the game a little bit that's
maneuvering that line I just wanted to
give you the heads up I feel like that's
like real good when someone says it is
however it also gets it's also a way of
saying hey I ratted you out
i ratted you out depending on what its
followed with it's like hey I want to
give you a heads up the boss you know
asked me about this and I didn't know
how to respond so I said this and
come and talk to you so I just wanted to
give you a heads up that's that's
different that I hate just to give you a
heads up
I talked to the boss earlier today I
told him what your deal is like that
that's not good for you so yeah there's
all kinds of shades of grey there as
well and you know I worked for for a
while I was the Admirals aide and so and
I worked for a really great guy great
Admiral who I had a really good
relationship with you know and if I
needed something he was gonna give it to
me and so when I was at asking to
Commander which is what which is what
job I went to immediately when I got
done working for the Admiral I literally
had a direct line to the Admiral
because I had his cell phone number I
had his office number and if I wanted to
call him he wanted to talk to me because
we were friends but that doesn't mean
that I went to him and you know did all
kinds of you know I didn't do that
no I never took advantage of that and at
all and was always professional but
there is this little story where as hot
as this might sound we were getting
ready to go on deployment and we needed
a what's called a large-format color
printer yeah and it prints out big
pieces of paper large format and you
need it because you need to make battle
map yeah and you need it good one
because when you are on an operation
every single guy in the platoon has a
map mm-hmm so you could have you might
need 8 10 12 15 30 you might need 30
color laminated maps to go out on a
mission and for whatever reason I think
we had one it was kind of crappy and the
boss the Admiral you know I talked to
him before I was going on deployment I
don't know if he called me or I ran into
him or whatever and he's the Admiral in
charge of everything and he's just you
know getting a feel for what's going on
and he says um you know hey you
everything you need for deployment cuz
he knew I was leaving in a couple days
or a couple week couple weeks and I said
yeah you know sir we're good to go
you know right now believe it or not I'm
just waiting on a printer gotta get one
of those large format printers for
battle maps but other than that were
we're rockin and rollin and like that
afternoon I got back to my office and
the Commodore so now it's two bosses
above my immediate boss at the seal team
and one guy below the Admiral
we don't had like a message for me it
was like hey and luckily I was friends
with hey I guess you need a printer let
me know what kind he's like thanks for
the heads up and I was like hey sorry
sir I just saw man the kwik-e-mart or
whatever but uh but yeah you know you
you got a you got a you don't want to
abuse that stuff at all and you got a
got to be smart about it and it's really
always is I'm telling you it's always
it's it's not good to skip the chain of
command
it really isn't it's not gonna it
generally is not gonna benefit you it
generally gonna put you in a bad
situation it's gonna give you less
leverage with your immediate boss
because if I went above the chain
command on you even with you get
redirected by our boss you are pissed
yeah and you're gonna you're gonna
sabotage yeah it's like it's like really
it's a version of going behind someone's
back oh for sure it is yeah and it
almost even feels like you and if you
tell them it feels like oh you're
cleaning up up my hand yeah yes it's a
really it's a really it's a tough one
you gotta you gotta use caution with
that one and also I'll tell you what
else it is it's it's an easy it's it
appears to be the easy way out like if
you're not listening me all problems
could go above the chain of command
instead of me influencing you explaining
to you writing point papers to you
building a relationship with you so that
you trust me instead of doing all those
things that take time and effort and
tact I'm gonna skip the chain of command
until your boss so that's that's another
negative about it it's a cop-out you
shouldn't need to do it I can't like
that printer story I just told you like
other than that me going above the chain
of command and that was almost a comical
thing like I said I was friends with the
Commodore too who always took great care
of me and was laughing when he left the
message I go thanks for the heads up you
know he wasn't mad when he said that he
was you know he was laughing because
here I was
getting ready to deploy to Iraq and what
I want is a printer that's what we need
which can tell you how dialed in we were
and how much great gear yeah because the
only thing that was left that we needed
was a printer you know that's where I
was at I got all the everything we
needed but I need a printer so you went
above his head get it for the printer
but you got to you know other than that
it's really hard for me to think of
other times in my naval career where I
went above someone in the chain of
command it just didn't happen you know
I'm gonna take the time to build a
relationship with my immediate boss and
they're gonna do what I wanted to do
yeah they're gonna give me what I wanted
to give me they're gonna support me the
way I needed to get supported that's
what I'm gonna do
yeah that's leading up the chain of
command skipping the chain of command
isn't really leadership yeah so try not
to do it kind of like when you're a kid
and you're you got to deal with your
older brother or something but instead
of dealing with him you go and tattle on
him something like that yes I feel ya
know it's the same same similar thing
nothing my little brother tattled on me
ever yeah interesting how you and it
seems like this is a common theme to how
you were like you want to try the most
and the best you can to deal with it
yourself like the most for sure like
from the beginning on it I mean just
like how you were saying how like if you
got to fire someone you know where you
want to get to the point where you
within the beginning yeah yeah like you
can't like just let them do the wrong
thing you mean yeah that's cool let them
do it for years and then be like you
know what you're fired because of all
these wrong things and you didn't even
bring it and I think about this too like
on the unethical things you you might be
again I'm gonna I'm gonna walk a fine
line here but you might not recognize
you might not recognize that what you're
doing is unethical you might be like hey
Jocko
you know what I do is I just I always
hit everyone with this little extra $12
charge you know no big deal no one ever
notices it and you know we're working
hard and you might just hey man it gives
you food for your kids and you're
working on a bunch of rich people's
houses so they can afford 12 bucks and
it's not that big of a deal to you and
maybe somebody that you started working
for it did the same thing that's kind of
just the standard operating procedure
yeah where's the house like man you know
what that's not good you know that's
actually it might not seem like a big
deal but you're taking money you you
know you know that put
money on your table gives you feed your
kids it's taking money off their table
yeah you know and whether they're rich
or not money's money yes I don't think
for you I don't feel like we should be
doing you know I mean I become might
awaken you and get your ethics back on
track and you might be a good dude cuz
just because someone was skimming some
money doesn't mean they're horrible
person right it means that they went
down the wrong path
just because someone goes down the wrong
path doesn't mean they can come back big
doesn't mean they cannot come back to
the right path man if I was if I was you
know executed every time I did something
that was stupid or bad or you know I
shouldn't have done I would have died a
thousand deaths by now right
we grow up and we learn these things we
become better people but we only become
better people we only learn these things
if somebody teaches them to us yeah now
we can learn the hard way which is you
know yeah all of a sudden someone looks
at you and goes away what's this charge
for twelve bucks and then they follow up
all your receipts for the last five
years you've been working here and then
they realize you've stolen money from
the company and stole money from these
customers and they're gonna prosecute
you because stealing over X amount of
dollars is a felony you know what I mean
so then you learn your lesson but that's
not the lesson we want to learn so
having those tough conversations like
you're talking about having them up
front and whether it's your own we right
whether it's counseling somebody whether
it's dealing with you know my boss who I
want to tell like hey that I think
there's a better way to do this any of
those the earlier you do them the easier
that are to have and the longer you wait
to do them the harder they get yeah so
also to it's just an overall help like I
don't know it's hard to not draw the
analogy noting knowledge but the
comparison between like your boss and
subordinates type situation and
parenting kids you know like for sure
just like are you saying sometimes
people don't know necessarily that it's
unethical or they don't know it's that
unethical or somewhere like that that's
that's it I mean in my situation with
kids like they don't know essentially
they don't know better you know like I
don't know you take a permanent pen and
you draw all over the walls here four or
five years old and you're like yeah sure
I've been drawing on paper this whole
time so there's no reason for me to
think sure I should draw on the walls
but there's really nothing to tell me
not so they do it and then
go get like beat or something like never
just yelled at or something some some
punishment straight-up punishment
instead of you know okay you didn't know
that you have to know this you know it's
like that kind of roll I got a I'm gonna
tell a story we were I was going through
Officer Candidate School and there's a
manual and you're going through officer
cadets go I can't remember what it's but
it's all the rules of officer Kenneth's
going everything you this is our uniform
supposed to be this is the way your
locker supposed to be these are the way
you stand in line at the chow hall all
do every single rule is in this book and
I forget what it's called so you live by
the code of this book it's very specific
rules and there was a kid who was going
through Officer Candidate School with us
and he was from another country he'd
been raised another country and became
an American citizen but he was from
another country and grew up in a really
poor you know a really poor kid so good
for him I mean he had achieved a
incredible amount finishing college
going to Officer Candidate School was
awesome but he had some habits from
growing up in the third world that were
a little bit different for you know for
Americans and one of the things that he
would do is he would urinate in the
shower and and not just while he was
taking a shower but when you come back
from a class or something you know you'd
everyone have to go to the bathroom at
the same time and so you know guys would
go in and fill up the urinals and then
there's nowhere to piss are what are you
gonna do oh well he would just go in the
shower and it's a big open shower he
just go in there piss right in the drain
like it was nothing toilet chow yeah so
let's shower or whatever and one of the
American kids and I'm calling the kids
he's got a roll you know actually we had
a but some of them were new kids fresh
out of college the kid the the kid that
was urinating in the shower was fresh
out of college and one of the older guys
who was like me was a prior enlisted guy
he came to me and he said hey man this
kids urinating in the shower like all
the time and I said I said okay well you
know we're on the water he said man I
got to get to he's a cop he's like you
know my squads in charge of cleaning the
showers and so these are my guys on
there on the ground cleaning up his piss
it ain't cool and I was like all right
cool
I'll talk to him so I went I said hey
man I said hey you know officer
candidate whatever can I can I talk to
you for a second he goes yeah and he
comes in
as today man you um you know you're
you're pissing in the shower just wait
for a tile --it and he looked at me like
I was telling him that he shouldn't
breathe air right he was like well why
and I said I said well no because you
know you're pissin where everyone walks
around and and he goes yeah I would
throw water to drain all my nights and
he goes and I said no it's it's not just
just don't do it he goes it's not in the
rule book there's what he said to me and
I go what do you mean he goes uh he
named the manual he goes it doesn't say
in there that you can't piss in the
showers well doesn't say you get piss on
my floor either or in my bed but I don't
want you doing that but it was
interesting my point is that his
viewpoint was like this was totally
normal
Annie and he was a great kid not just a
hard worker but for him he was just like
what are you talking about why wouldn't
I piss in the shower all the all the
pisser's are taken
I'm gonna go piss in the shower well
next question let's move on I got work
to do and so I had to explain to him hey
man listen it's it's a little different
in people that are cleaning the showers
don't want to be on their hands and
knees in your piss yeah so any he said
okay he listened to me and but I could
see that he listened to me but he didn't
100% agree with me right no he was like
okay yeah you kind of did that you know
yeah and it was one of those where I I'm
trying to explain to him the why but it
just it's like you're saying I he
literally didn't understand that that
was not acceptable from a hygienic point
hygienic right hygienic from a hygienic
point from a you know a moral or a
morale point of the bow yeah yeah
they're cleaning up yeah that was uh
that was good times you never seen that
Seinfeld
you watch Seinfeld ever and what that is
it's caught one of the guys gets caught
taking a leak in the shower at the gym
you know yeah the gym you take a shower
and then it's like you know they catch
you and they you're ostracized basically
I think they even took his man I don't
know but he's like you you believe this
there whatever you know they're they're
mad at me for you know pissing in the
shower at the gym and he's like this is
like why are you confused that they're
mad at you kind of thing
it's all pipe so don't you know he's
trying to defend it and you can kind of
see we're in a small teeny tiny way if
you don't think about it yeah why not
it's going down the drain you're not
pissing on the on the people hey I was
deployed on a ship and I was an officer
as an ensign so I just moved up from the
from the troop ver thing where I used to
be with the enlisted spine so we used to
proudly call ourselves almost on I was
up in the in the officer area in the
what they call those area the officer
country was a little science officer
country you know no enlisted allowed
yeah totally leave us so I'm in there
and I'm living with we actually had four
other seals a seal officers in this room
if one of the seal officers there was a
sink in the room but no bathroom so you
just had a sink you brush your teeth
shave whatever but if you want to know
the bathroom me to go down the hallway
where the showers and the pisser's were
and so one night I'm you know I'm like
get stirred awake by some noise and I
see one of the my fellow officers is
pissing in the sink right and sink and
you know I was like hey man what are you
doing I'm not walking all the way then
down to the down to the bathroom I was
like yeah yeah actually yes you are
that's why I brushed my teeth Holmes and
he and he was the same way he was kind
of surprised like what's wrong with you
yeah just piss and it's the same pipes
but look now do me a favor
just walk on down there what if he
urinated in sink regularly but every
single time when he was done he scrubbed
the sink with like Lysol and stuff bro
it's also called you call it that well
it's not such a psychological but that
doesn't even make it worth it no you
might as well walk down there right I
dig it but like what if fellas just this
thing I mean well how would you feel
about it
don't piss in my sink Yeah right it's
like a it's like a it's like a what do
you call it customary almost for reasons
of course yeah the reason is don't piss
I say actually in college we play poop
on with it like a nice facility to at
you H but the showers were like guys
would do it all the time
and but the showers were shaped
different we're like let's say you're
facing the shower right or you're facing
the wall at the bottom of the wall was
like a gutter trench in trench yeah so
it went down so if you did and one guys
would it would go to a you weren't ever
standing in it you know so if you're
standing in it that's like of obvious
you know but but guys would do it and
when I first saw it I was like dang he's
just openly doing it like one of this
guy actually mentions his name is farm
like I mention because it's in his
shower but he's like talking to me while
he's pissing in the shower almost like
it was a straight-up toilet it was a
said he's like yeah I'll talking about
I'm like all right
that's how so again it's more like the
ethics of the like the culture almost
its what it seemed like yeah when it
seems like to me is don't piss in my
sink different ballgame yeah shower okay
understood right like you said it goes
down the drain
it's there's water flowing all over it
yeah you're washing it off any washing
off the soup coming over it but uh you
know what I got a good idea just as a
general overall rule yeah pissing the
toy yeah I try the toy yes we'd better
do that one yeah the same way you
probably not going to brush your teeth
in the toilet yeah you and that's what
the sink is now if you want to pit if
you want a brush your teeth in the
toilet
have at it I won't be mad at you I'll be
mad at you bet I don't know if I hang
out with you as much or whatever but
yeah I understand it makes sense and was
not spoil it from talking about skipping
the chain of command oh yeah that's
right because the guide OCS Officer
Candidate School
yeah jettison in the shower had to let
him know up you gotta have the hard
conversations I wonder what ever
happened him he's a hard work where we
see from somewhere like Vietnam or or
Laos or something maybe Thailand yeah so
some Asian Asian country Southeast Asian
country hard worker and smart yeah I
would think yeah my opinion about taking
a leak in the shower is you shouldn't do
it but if like like this guy who's like
oh that's normal that doesn't like
totally surprised me though ya know it
doesn't surprise me but makes sense that
guys did I like it though for sure
next question